[Music]
[Applause]
before I get to Albert Breer I want to
ask Albert about this but Dan orlovski
was on Pat McAfee's show yesterday and
he was talking about Bill bich here is
McAfee's question now Diana Rini
reported this weekend that people around
the building are assuming or preparing
for a mutual parting of ways between
bill bich and the New England Patriots
he will go coach somewhere else if that
is the case will he be the GM as well we
assume but who knows that would be
bananas that would be a colossal move in
the NFL news cycle I've heard that I've
heard more and more of that over the
past like week I'm not a reporter all
that stuff but I have heard that you're
a
journalist yeah um I I have heard that
that's going to be the case and it's
kind of who who knows the likelihood of
it but i' I've heard that that's going
to happen and I've heard the location is
already kind of determined as well where
he's going
Lao
Chargers you I'm not
giv
I I just I've heard that okay let's
bring in Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback what the hell is orlovski
saying I mean I don't know if a
destination's been determined um I would
say this though like you know the
Washington stuff has been out there for
a while and you know it's something
that's been talked about in NFL circles
for more than the time that it's been
out there in the public and um you know
that one's interesting to me um just
because you know if you look at the
history of things Dan like we've seen
like owners bring in older coaches um
with a track record it's generally a
credibility play you know like shod Khan
needed credibility in Jacksonville so he
brought in Tom Coughlin at the beginning
of Steve Ross's ownership um you know in
in in Miami they had Bill parcel's there
as the football Z are so um it would
make sense if you're trying to restore
credibility to your organization and
your Josh Harris and Josh Harris by the
way would be able to negotiate this with
the Patriots because he went to Harvard
Business School at Jonathan Craft and
they've had a relationship going back
over 30 years so there are some Doc
connecting you can do there that would
make that one um make a lot of sense I
do think Bill still wants to coach um
now that's just my opinion um based on
you know what I've heard from people who
know him really really well and who
around him um you know that shul record
is sitting out there um he's 16 wins
away I think at one point we thought it
was likely that he would get there in
2024 that looks a lot less likely now so
if you're the Patriots and you're
talking about hanging on to him and he's
pursuing that Sho record you'd be
talking about another two years maybe
now um so there's a lot of things there
you know like where you can say it would
make some sense um so you know the two
teams you hear most connected to to to
to Bill have been at least you know from
my perspective been Washington and
Dallas and um both in the NFC East both
historic franchises both with owners
that badly want to win um you know
obviously in different spots in their
ownership um but it should be
interesting going forward and um look I
mean if you want to look at if you want
to go way back in history I know I'm
being long-winded here but this is a
complex topic uh you know like the last
two times the Patriots changed coaches
um there was a trade involved you know
they they went from you know dealing
Bill Parcels to the Jet and they hired
Pete Carroll and then when they brought
bich in there was a trade with the jet
that happened there too and in both
cases both parcels and bich had things
lined up before the season ended so
wouldn't surprise me if there's some
back Channel communication that happens
you know towards the end of the year
what are the Bills
doing the bills right now are um you
know I would
say the the move here is to try to spark
the team and um you know I don't want to
say that the windows closing because I
do think when you have a quarterback
like Josh Allen the window remains open
you know the window is Josh Allen's
career but you know with this particular
group of players they're getting older
and you know clearly something isn't
working so you know I think one of the
things you do in bringing up bringing in
Joe Brady is you change the atmosphere
um in the in the meeting rooms and um
you know on that offense of Staff um I
think the hope is you know Joe Brady
through being really organized um a good
Communicator a guy who's really
inclusive is going to be able to spark
something with the quarterback and with
the offense as a whole and um what if
they win that game Albert I mean if they
don't have 12 players on the field then
they win the game is Ken dorsy fired if
they win that game no I don't think so I
mean you're in a short week too think
about that part of it right like you're
in a short week and you know I if you
win the game I don't think you do it and
I understand what you're saying you know
like where they um you know like it's
you know there was you know game
Operation problems there that falls on
the head coach no question you know 12
guys getting on the field like that
falls on the special teams coach but
also falls on the head coach that the
game Operation was an issue for them and
getting the team out there um you know
the defense obviously you have the flag
at the end of the game on on on uh on on
on on on the throw down field to Jerry
Judy so um yeah I mean I I think it's
very easy to look at this and say yes
this is more than just an offensive
problem I do think that they recognize
with Matt Milano down with TR travius
white down that the offense is going to
have to carry the team and the offense
can't turn the ball over anymore and the
offense needs to be more consistent and
I think that this is a move to try to
get a little bit more out of the offense
for sure and you know we'll see with Joe
Brady you know I I could tell you this
like teams that interviewed him in 20121
um after his first year with the
Panthers thought he was a superstar um
one team I know like Kim really close to
reversing course on their own hire and
hiring him so there are a lot of people
in the league that think a lot of Joe
Brady um obviously he did a good job at
LSU before um Carolina there was a bit
of a personality conflict between him
and Matt rule which I think you know
wound up being the reason why he wound
up uh you know it didn't work out in
2021 um you know we'll see if he's as
smart as a lot of people think he is
then he should be able to make a
difference here down the stretch yeah
but I'm looking at Buffalo's stats uh
they were second in points in yards last
year they're eighth in points this year
seventh in
yards it is the offense a problem is the
quarterback I think it's the consistency
I think it's
consistency I like honestly like for me
Dan this is why I thought I thought they
should have tried to trade for saquon
Barkley or Jonathan Taylor like in the
summer like I I I if I was them like
that would be what I would do because I
I think what they need is they they need
just to be more consistent down to down
and in less Long yard yage situations
and you know where they get themselves
in trouble is when it just all goes on
Josh as long as Josh is there they're
going to be a top 10 offense that should
be the Baseline right like what I see
and what other teams that have played
against them that I've talked to have
seen is they get themselves in these
long yardage situations and it's okay
Josh go make a play you know how do they
get in second and six and third two more
consistently I think you started to see
it on Monday night when they really got
James Cook going like where they can go
offensively it's just not consistently
enough looking like that and you know I
think if they had had again like this
was just my idea but if you had like a
Taylor or a Barkley in there now you got
Josh Allen playing off of play action a
little bit more you're in second and six
and third and two more um you're giving
yourself a great chance to be terrifying
offensively you know when you know the
first play when on first down there's a
negative play and now all of a sudden
you you're in second and third team well
it becomes a lot easier to defend
everything and and the likelihood of a
turnover goes way up so I think the idea
here is like can we find a way to be a
little bit more consistent on offense
because we know right now based on the
makeup of our team and our defensive
injuries that the offense is going to
have to carry the team if we're going to
go where we want to go Albert Bri by the
way by the way like this has worked
before like I don't know if you remember
10 years ago like John Harbaugh firing
Cam Cameron in the middle of the season
and and and Jim Caldwell comes in and
they win a Super Bowl so it's not like
there's not track record of this sort of
thing Happ worked before he's Albert
Breer the Monday Morning Quarterback
their senior NFL reporter the likelihood
that Jim harau is in the NFL does it
increase or decrease given what he's
involved with now increase um you know I
I think he's sick of the NCAA I think he
likes it in Michigan I think he's sick
of the NCAA I think he's sick of dealing
with all this and like a lot of that's
his own fault like you know 100% but
like I think all the Hoops that you have
to to jump through to be a college coach
is a lot anyway you know with nil and
the transfer portal all the different
stuff that they have to deal with on a
day-to-day basis as college coaches and
then you throw the NCAA stuff on top of
it and the fact that he's got unfinished
business in the NFL I think that this
makes it more likely that he goes to the
NFL um and I quite frankly think if the
opportunity is out there for him he's
probably going um now is that in Vegas
would that work for Mark Davis who's
tried to hire him in the past maybe
would that be Chicago can he work with
Kevin Warren you remember he and Kevin
Warren were at odds a couple years ago
when Kevin Warren was the um commi was
the commissioner of the Big 10 and Kevin
Warren you know from all accounts wants
to be involved on the football side in
Chicago would that work I don't know but
I think he could make a difference in
both those places and people forget how
good an NFL coach he was and I think one
of the things that you can say about Jim
Harbaugh that's probably the biggest I I
think as as big a compliment as you can
give him is he has a style of play that
is so distinctive and travels everywhere
he goes like his teams at Stanford look
like his teams the Niners look like his
teams at Michigan and so if you bring
him in you almost certainly could have
like that sort of thing you know you
could have a very identifiable style of
play coming in and oh by the way what if
the Bears or Raiders have a top 10 pick
and maybe he has a shot attracting JJ
McCarthy it's an interesting idea yeah
but I don't know if Mark Davis is going
to Shell out that kind of money again
because he's paying Gruden he's paying
Josh McDaniels yeah and I don't know you
know that that that that's a very fair
question that's a very fair question um
but I mean he was on the doorstep of
hiring he tried to hire Harbaugh you
know and like was right there in 2015
when Harbaugh decided to go to Michigan
um and you know like he interviewed
actually a GM candidate a couple years
ago and Ed dods who works for the Colts
who has a good relationship with
Harbaugh who I I think is going to be on
the Raiders radar are again when they're
looking at GM candidates so I I think
the Raiders are definitely one to keep
an eye on again the money part of it
could come in and be a factor um but I
do think that you know Jim definitely
has some unfinished business in the NFL
and the Raiders would be an interesting
landing spot for him if the Chargers
don't make the
playoffs what
happens I think it's so I think by all
accounts I think you'd agree with this
right that roster is really good yeah so
if you get rid of the head coach do you
keep the general manager because this is
Tom Tesco's thirdd head this would be
Tom Tesco's fourth head coach you know
um I don't know I don't know and and it
does feel to me like you know I just
talked about Buffalo's window I I think
the Chargers are sort of in a similar
spot to Buffalo right like where it's
like you know like the quarterback's
there and you're probably going to be
good as long as the quarterbacks there
but for this particular group of players
right Joey Bosa Cleo Mack Derwin James
Keenan Allen Austin Eckler it's not that
they don't have young players in the
team they do they've got good young
players in some spots like you know ran
Slater probably be a really really good
um left tackle for a long time for them
you know but the current core of players
is a is starting to age out a little and
so do you feel an urgency to bring in a
guy who can be that guy for you and put
you over the top all like John Gruden
going to the Campa Bay Buccaneers in in
2002 you know where you feel like we got
to do the we got to do everything we can
to get the most out of this particular
group of players so let's take a big
swing now um I certainly could see
something like that happening um and
again Brandon Staley's got a chance now
to to prove who he is as a head coach
over the next two months but um you know
based on the fact that you know
contractually he's at a point where
there generally a decision point on
whether you extend a guy or fire a guy
um and where they've been as a team over
the last you know three years whether
they're getting better all of that um
you know absolutely this is a this is a
critical couple months for Brandon
Staley and that franchise good to talk
to you as always Albert thank you
awesome thanks Dan that's Albert Breer
the Monday Morning Quarterback